[Musique]
les gens jette alors qu'il pourrait
continuer à le manger que ça changement
le goût dans certains aliments l'une des
premières choses que l'on vérifie avant
de mettre un article dans notre panier
d'épicerie la date de péremption on a un
système au Canada à une date le meilleur
avant qui est pas une garantie de
salubrité c'est une garantie que
l'aliment va être meilleur gustativement
et nutritionnellement jusqu'à la date
qu'on veut donner
l'affichage meilleur avant est
obligatoire pour tous les aliments qui
ont une durée de conservation de moins
de 90 jours
cette date est valide tant que le
produit n'est pas déballé donc la date
tombe quand on ouvre un paquet
au Québec il y a une exception pour
l'étiquetage de la viande et du poisson
qui doit plutôt indiquer la mention
emballé le il faut que l'épicerie mette
un écriteau dans le haut de l'étalage
réfrigéré ou on va la durée de
conservation pour tous les aliments qui
se retrouvent dans les carrelage donc ça
va être écrit par exemple la poitrine de
poulet c'est 24 à 48 heures après
l'emballage
la France préfère les consommateurs à
deux dates dans le cas d'aliments à
risque comme les viandes poissons fruits
de mer soit la date à laquelle l'aliment
doit être consommé et la date
d'emballage
les denrées emballées telles que
biscuits céréales bouillant on la
mention à consommer de préférence avant
donc un système comme ça premièrement
les gens sont moins inquiets ça mène à
moins de confusion puis ça mène selon
moi à moins gaspillage
ça peut être alléchant d'acheter des
crevettes à 30% de rabais ces aliments
là c'est permis des vendre ici au Québec
les aliments même sont périmés mais
c'est pas recommandé de manger des
charcuteries ou des viandes de poissons
crus après la date parce qu'un risque
pour la santé
on utilise souvent nos sens lorsque la
couleur a changé est-ce que ça sent bon
est-ce que c'est une bonne idée on peut
pas se casser sens parce que les
micro-organismes pathogènes le fameux
colis la salmonelle Listeria c'est les
classiques des rappels mais ils ne
changent ni l'odeur ni l'apparence ni le
goût de l'aliment
[Musique]
l'emballage a aussi un impact sur la
durée de vie d'un aliment
quand on a un emballage comme ça emballé
à l'épicerie c'est sûr c'est le moins
performant on emballage comme ça on les
appelle ça des barquettes c'est toujours
en balade usine donc ce qu'on veut
souvent c'est de retirer l'oxygène on le
remplace par de l'azote qui est un gaz
linerte tant qu'ils sont dans son
emballage bien fermé avec l'atmosphère
modifié ou le sous vide ça se concerne
longtemps donc on ouvre une barquette de
poitrine de poulet bien l'oxygène vient
en contact avec la viande et là il y a
des réactions d'oxydation qui fait que
la viande conserve moins longtemps si
l'emballage n'a pas été ouvert les
risques de prolifération de bactéries
pathogènes sont minces
ici on a trois boissons mais plusieurs
dates qui veulent dire des choses
différentes comment les interprètes mais
premièrement ici on a un exemple de
tétrapage donc c'est un emballage qu'on
peut conserver aux garde-manger donc
température pièce il y a pas de problème
par contre quand on va l'ouvrir il faut
le réfrigérer et ça durait diminue
vraiment beaucoup un truc conservation
pour le lait on parle de environ 30
jours de durée de conservation quand on
ouvre et on ferme l'emballage ça change
pas vraiment la durée le jus lui est
acide donc il rentre dans une catégorie
d'aliments qu'on pourrait se permettre
de dépasser un petit peu la date de
quelques jours même si c'est dépassé
parce qu'il y a l'acidité qui va le
protéger
les produits laitiers qui contiennent
beaucoup d'eau tel le yogourt les
fromages frais ou en saumure se
conservent moins longtemps que les
fromages à pâte ferme ou le parmesan ici
mon yogourt est très beau à l'oeil mais
la date est dépassée de plusieurs
semaines est-ce que je peux le manger
mettons si c'est moins d'une semaine
peut-être mais plusieurs semaines
il pourrait avoir justement présence de
Monsieur même des fois si on les voit
pas nécessairement ça peut se retrouver
à l'intérieur si la moisissure a créé
des toxines la toxine va pouvoir
pénétrer dans l'ensemble du yogourt mais
si la moisissure prend sur un fromage à
pâte ferme à côté mais là on pourrait
tout simplement enlever une partie sous
la moisissure et le manger parce que
c'est pas liquide c'est fromage blanc
peut se permettre de dépasser là de
plusieurs jours même semaine sur les
dates de péremption dans les plats
préparés souvent là qu'on va gaspiller
comment on interprète bien les dates de
péremption pour éviter de jeter trop
mais en fait ici on a une belle variété
de préparer on a des plats préparés mis
dans des barquettes tout à fait
standards qui se conservent quelques
jours on a dû sous vide quelques
semaines de dire conservation on a des
boîtes de conserve qui se conservent
quelques années puis en plus la
température de la pièce par contre une
fois qu'on ouvre ses emballages là la
durée est toute la même peu importe ces
trois à cinq jours en général pour les
aliments qui vont être préparés
[Musique]
n'oublions pas qu'il faut aussi
appliquer les conditions de
réfrigération et de congélation optimale
pour étirer la durée de vie d'un aliment
par exemple le lait placé dans la porte
est plus sujet à une variation de
température que si les rangées sur une
tablette alors comment savoir combien de
temps conserver un produit ouvert avant
de le consommer
la meilleure façon c'est de se fier à
des outils comme le thermoguide de ma
pack
c'est une liste des aliments les plus
communs puis on va voir la durée de
conservation selon son eau congélateur
c'est ce qui est fun parce que quand on
n'est pas un scientifique c'est dur à
s'imaginer concrètement c'est quoi la
durée si je l'ouvre si je le garde fermé
etc c'est difficile à savoir
instinctivement